at least one person has been shot dead
and a number of others
injured during a third night of protest
in the u.s city of kenosha
social media footage appears to show
civilians with guns
and one victim with a head wound the
gunfire
started in the early hours of wednesday
after hundreds of protesters
defied a dawn to dusk curfew and clashed
with police
who then responded with tear gas and
rubber bullets
now the unrest was sparked after police
shot jacob blake a black
resident seven times in the back
blake's attorney and family say that the
shots left blake paralyzed
and fighting for his life
chef and simons is joining us live now
from kenosha with the very latest stuff
and three people
shot in this protest we're hearing
reports of that there in wisconsin
what more can you tell us
yeah i can tell you that this came
definitely as a surprise for
um all of the people on the street
probably and definitely for the press
which was
accompanying the police forces the law
enforcement uh forces
trying to disperse the rather large
crowd of protesters
tonight in this third night of protest
and unrest here in kenosha wisconsin
police was largely successful in this
effort to enforce the curfew
for the first time in three nights
pushing
protesters down a main street when
suddenly
the press present as well as the
protesters heard a
burst of shots um and this was
immediately identifiable as
shot from a long gun uh ar-15
m16 type semi-automatic weapon
uh then the second burst and then we saw
um protesters rushing towards us and
actually two was the police
which had advanced in in armored
vehicles
asking screaming at the police for help
and forcing them or encouraging them to
rush down to a scene which we
have to say that also had not seen we
have no we had no visual
there that was too far away and it was
too dark however uh confirmed now
one person dead what has transpired
there according to witnesses we spoke
is that a uh libertarian
military militia type person
that's the words of the witnesses
felt threatened by protesters
and shot one protester in the head
and this protest was protester was
delivered to the hospital which wasn't
far away but
it looks like has to come to his
injuries another two people
injured i also talked to witnesses who
said there are more than five people who
got actually shot
but that is not confirmed confirmed as
of now three people shot
again not from police but these are
civilians who are shooting each other
now last sentence to this this is really
a surprise
no it wasn't not for us probably not for
many people in in
kenosha wisconsin because we have seen
throughout the day
more and more white people uh in
camouflage
with the rifles shotguns
ar-15 m16 semi-automatic weapons
handguns of all calibers from nine
millimeter to 45 millimeters and so on
um flooding the streets and not
in a confrontative way towards the
protesters but also not in a very
um nice way so they stayed separated
stefan simon's bringing us up to date
there um
a night of unrest again in kenosha
wisconsin
as you've mentioned one person now
confirmed dead
in that unrest stefan thanks so much for
your reporting
of course
you